hey guys thanks so much for tuning in to
another episode middle ground this
episode focuses on education speaking of
Education a big thank you to our sponsor
Skillshare for those of you don't know
Skillshare is a super cool online
community where you can take thousands
of courses and learn like creative
skills and all these other different
skills stick around after the episode to
learn a little bit more we'll see you
after but how much better is it for you
when they say oh where do you go to
school and you can go I go to Yale and
then they go oh my gosh that's so cool
you must be so smart for me when I go oh
I go to lbcc and they're like oh
immediately I feel like maybe a money
the upper climes of the East Coast
there's as much of a need for Ivy League
as there is for every University I did
gen - all eight Ivy League schools
people might think that it's really
expensive which it is I personally have
respect for anybody who does something
in their life to try to advance
themselves to make themselves succeed
going to Princeton is a big part of my
identity right now and I hope that
through this discussion I can kind of
break that a little bit and I'm curious
to know what it's like for them going to
school paying tuition I'm open for a bit
of education about the Ivy League today
[Music]
hi I'm Cassandra I'm a student at Yale
hi I'm Cory I also go to Yale I'm Emily
I go to Princeton
I'm Trinity I go to lbcc I'm so I
graduated recently from Santa Monica
Community College I'm Aidan and I
currently attend or vine Valley College
yeah so in high school like everybody
knew me as the guy who wanted to go to
Yale I'm surrounded by people who all
are affiliated with you who lift me up
who support me and what I do who support
me in my job search who support me in my
career who support basically my entire
life so yeah my life right now revolves
around my school and I love it I love
this question because I struggled a lot
with us going into Princeton
I think well I played soccer my whole
life and I got recruited to play soccer
Princeton and then going into Princeton
and being a really good soccer player
for my hometown and then being on a team
with girls who were all the best in
their hometown is like oh now Who am I
I'm not the best anymore at this through
Princeton I've tried to reconstruct my
identity and another part of that is
that I am Christian and so like
combining my faith with being an Ivy
League student has been incredible
Community College in itself is like a
very it feels very temporary like no one
really has that madhuri that you guys
have like you know in like 30 years
you're gonna see somebody you're like oh
you went to Yale and it's me I don't
know your mascot is what is it Bulldogs
Bulldogs
it's like this thing and it's like
forever some like oh why Kings like
whatever my school mascot when you have
multiple identities when you identify
with a lot of different labels you might
not find that community at your school
like as a whole but you might find it
like within that small subsection like
I'm queer and trans and I found a small
community of like LGBT like the LGBTQ
Club at my school being able to find a
community of some kind is still nice
even if like like you said it is really
temporary I've been around long enough
to realize that there is nothing school
service in the army none of these things
I think define us they are a part of us
but what defines us is what we
accomplish in life maybe that's some of
the wisdom I've been able to pick up in
85 years but that said you are what you
do not necessarily what you attend I
agree with what you're saying and I
think it's very valid that you're
defined by how you are as a person by
your character by what you do but I also
think that it's Yale that built my
character that makes me like the person
I am yeah but Yale you're the one who
got into Yale right it came from here
and you Yale didn't put that into you
it wasn't really a choice for me when I
was in high school my grades were really
bad and just in general like kind of the
stigma against community college
students and going to a community
college there's a level of resentment
towards Ivy League schools kind of just
in general because I think it's also
because I did used to want to go to one
when I was younger
[Applause]
don't everybody rush forward when I
first decided to go to Santa Monica
Community College I spent an hour on the
campus just looking at who was there and
I realized that there had to be
something extremely fair about it
because of the diversity I was seeing I
was seeing people of every color of
every age obviously I was welcomed there
nobody questioned my being too old for a
college an argument yeah I did my entire
application process online it took like
30 minutes for me to just send in my
name my information and suddenly like
hey congrats you're a student here like
community colleges are really really
forgiving but comparatively universities
like that's a whole other ballgame I
think why I was so hesitant on my answer
was because I was grappling between this
system itself versus the results of the
system there are ways that people can
help themselves get in like you're
recruited athlete a lot of people are
children of donors a lot of people have
legacies that is I guess inherently
unfair because that doesn't put
everybody on the same playing field the
scandal was that there was this one guy
who had this I guess fake company and
then he had certain relationships with
certain coaches at schools and then he
would have the coaches designate them as
recruited athletes to get them in I
might like to say this
yeah it's public it's public so our
soccer coach he was involved in the
scandal I think that it is what it is
you know it is a shame that it happened
but also the person who was involved in
it the family did not know about it it
was this was an example of this guy
taking an advantage of people who didn't
speak the language who didn't know about
the American admissions process you say
it is what it is but at the same time
is that person who gets in because
somebody paid $100,000 under the table
means somebody didn't get in who far
more deserved it definitely also makes
you think if this is just one Ivy League
how many more like prestigious schools
this is happening to if you're like okay
well then how many students are really
there because they deserve to be there
so I actually found out that I did know
that girl who was ultimately kicked out
and this like led to a lot of
discussions among me and my friends
should Yale kick her out she'll not and
also like the USC students as well I
feel anger when I think about like my
friends who Yale was their dream school
and they didn't get in and someone might
have unfairly taken that away from them
because of their privilege like that
just makes my blood boil but then again
I feel I feel really sad for this girl
in particular because like she didn't
know all she wanted to do was like
attend college I think the college
admissions system in general is is very
unfair and and a lot of it comes down to
luck right it depends who's reading your
application that day are they in a good
mood or are they in a bad mood do they
have a really great lunch or was their
lunch order late I definitely did I mean
like if you calculate the percentages of
so I got I applied for 17 schools and
got all 17 schools and I think that like
certain things I did in high school
definitely helped me stand out maybe
from like the see of applicants but it's
not something that you're like if I do X
Y & Z I will certainly get in it doesn't
work like that
I think a lot of times they can think
brilliant intelligent sometimes
privileged it's not always a positive
connotation that goes along with I
believe
yeah it's that's just kind of how it is
when you go to Community College
especially nowadays there's just so such
a stigma yeah like that makes me so sad
like I'm getting my education like I'm
bettering myself why do I feel like I'm
lesser than just because I don't have a
fancy name school on my like resume you
know what I mean yeah I think just like
the stigma that you guys mentioned I
think there's a stigma in the opposite
direction to where people who aren't in
the Ivy League they think like oh they
must think that they're better than us I
don't think people we don't think like
that I don't think like that
if you are proud of the school you go to
I'd be proud to show that off even if
other people would look down upon you
for that that's the people are gonna be
like that but I know and you probably
know that the people in your life that
care about you the people in my life
they care about me they don't care where
I went to school they'll support me no
matter what but there's also family
which is the thing and especially
because I'm I think the only one in my
family who is attending Community
College when I go to family reunions
they're like how school and I'm like
it's going great and they're like how
are you transferring soon and I'm like
no it's very it's like at best it's
awkward and at worst I feel like I'm the
family embarrassment absolutely and you
said that stigma around Ivy League
students I do believe there is one and I
totally get it but how much better is it
for you for someone for when they say oh
where do you go to school and you can go
I go to Yale and then they go oh my gosh
that's so cool how is it like you must
be so smart for me when I go oh I go to
lbcc and they're like oh that's that's
cool I think you're incredibly
well-spoken and intelligent and if you
think that your time going to Community
College is well worth it then you should
be really proud of that and not listen
to what people are saying or speculating
about you because where you go to school
well I think they're undervalued I think
they're known as the feeder to the
universities but I think one can get an
excellent education at a community
college
well my parents paid for my college
tuition in 1952 I was only 17 like maybe
some of you were when it happened with
you to know that I have parents who love
and support me enough where they say hey
if you want to go to Community College
we will help you and we will guide you
and I know that I'm really really lucky
to have that and because I know not
everybody who even goes to the same
school as I do has that growing up agent
American as a first generation my
parents came from China and same same as
your deal you know my mom very much
emphasized education from a young age
and yeah when I got into Yale she was
super super ecstatic and she was super
excited to what was it super excited to
pay for it but she would happily pay for
it because she knows that above all it
is the best for me
my Community College pays for the first
two years so I don't have to pay you to
ition which is great and I have five
brothers and sisters so it's like where
do I fit who's gonna make the sacrifice
to go to Community College to to pay for
their own tuition pay for their own
expenses and I just that was always the
option for me it was close it was like
five minutes away from where I live and
it was financially just a really good
option for me and I had a few friends
that went there
a fair price
at one point in American history college
was free or like practically nothing and
in a lot of countries outside of the US
tuition is really really low or you can
attend college for free but given the
current circumstances of where our
education system is now the tuition that
I have to pay is pretty low compared to
some of my friends who are attending
university and they have to pay
thousands and thousands of dollars for
me at Princeton I'm I'm very grateful
for the financial aid that they do give
me and they are very generous with my
family and I there were other schools
that I was looking at that didn't offer
financial aid and that wasn't a choice
for me and my family but for Princeton
they also offer students to have
on-campus jobs which I'm working three
and that has been really helpful I just
paid my fall bill it was about thirty
six thousand okay I think I got a go now
every year it only goes higher and
higher I mean granted we are at a great
university with great like facilities
and great amazing professors who like
when Pulitzer Prizes but I'm not sure
where every single aspect of that money
is going to that's ed I think like you
said earlier like they or at least Yale
provides really great financial aid and
definitely without that financial aid
I'm not sure I wouldn't have been able
to afford it and but the tuition itself
what people who are not on financial aid
have to pay I think is extremely high
the the purpose of a community college
is to provide an education for those who
can't afford it frankly I couldn't
afford it and they were they gave me a
free ride for the year and a half that I
spent there I wouldn't have been able to
go to school without it and that's that
makes me very grateful
I think I want to go into the finance
investment banking industry with a focus
on technique about it earlier how it's
like we both are interested in creative
writing and it's like I want to be a
novelist I want to be a writer
and it's like that doesn't pay anything
I'm gonna have no money I'm gonna be so
poor I'd hate to tell you but you have a
lot to worry about I'm an author I've
written half a dozen hooks and you may
wonder what I'm doing here who would
need a job at 85 well you want to know
something I wouldn't mind a job anybody
out there got one I realized I want to
change my mind we bumped them I realize
you know I'm not in as difficult as a
position you guys finance is the most
popular field that people from Yale and
Ivy League in general go into so because
of that a lot of the stress that we have
is self-imposed because we are competing
against the best people for not a lot of
jobs there is a fear of me that I'm not
going going to get you know the best job
or the job that I want but deep down I
know that I will end up with a job I was
kind of gonna say exactly what you were
gonna say I was gonna call you to out
like if the question was are you afraid
that you'll get a job that you love
that's well yes I am afraid and I'm
afraid I'm not gonna get a job you know
I think I will get a job there is a lot
of fear that I won't meet the standards
of where a Princeton student should be
working as our college mentioning to
people that I potentially wanted to be a
teacher or a social worker or work at a
non-profit and they're like you went to
Princeton to be a teacher
I'm like hang on that's not fair so I do
deal with that pressure a lot but I do
know I'm gonna get a job actually I
don't like saying that too much please
hire me but
yeah I think because of the community
there Yael really lifts up its artists
and I really wanted to be part of that
community that isn't competitive or
cutthroat but rather comes together to
support each other and collaborate more
than what you know I've always said that
when you pay for a school like Yale or
Princeton or any any school you're not
necessarily paying for the education I
don't think our education is $70,000
worth more than your education but I do
think what we are paying for is the
opportunities and the connections yes it
really helps to know the right people as
an author which I've been for 20 years
if I had the right agent and if I had
the right publisher then I would be
farther along in my career as a writer
you don't get a chance to network with
the same people that you guys and that
that makes a big difference so it's kind
of where you network as well as
networking I hate the word networking I
think like utility like you want
something that person knows you want
something from them so someone recently
said to me don't view it like networking
they said just go into the room and see
who do you who are the cool people there
that you want to be friends with it's
not like oh I'm just talking to you
because I want a job it's like I'm
genuinely interested how did you get
from point A to point B what do you do
in your day to day and that's how you
get to know those people
another thing someone recently told me
is that to be successful in this
industry but also many others you only
have to be two out of three things be
really really good at what you do be on
time or be very very kind like a good
person only one of the three is about
being good the other two isn't based on
like how smart you are I don't know that
kind of gives me hope
[Music]
that was so amazing Saul is so
inspirational and he just proves that
you're never too old to learn something
new a big thank you to our sponsor
Skillshare Skillshare is an amazing
online community where you can take
thousands of courses jublee loved the
color grading for filmmaking course by
dan dan leo
it's good both for working filmmakers
looking to improve their color
correction skills as well as for
aspiring filmmakers you just want to get
the basics of the craft premium
membership gives you unlimited access so
you can join the classes and communities
that are right for you so share is also
incredibly affordable especially when
compared to pricey in-person classes and
workshops an annual subscription is less
than $10 a month and because skills
respond to this episode you can get two
months of premium free with the link in
the description below oh my god two
months I'm gonna be pro by then you
already are thank you so much to
Skillshare and to you guys for watching
this episode make sure to subscribe
follow us on Instagram and we'll see you
next time
[Music]